Welcome to the Heavy Spoilers show, I'm your
host Paul aka the Zaniac on the floor and
this video we're breaking down Loki.
-
Season 2 episode 2 has just dropped and it's
packed with easter eggs, hidden details and
big reveals for the future.
Throughout this video we're gonna be braking
it down scene by scene to talk about all the
big reveals in it, things you missed and our
theories for episode 3. Heavy spoilers ahead
and if you enjoy the video then please smash
the like and make sure youre subcribed for
our videos every week. With that out the way,
huge thank you for clicking this, now let's
get into Loki!
-
Now we begin in Jolly London back in the year
1977. This is at the premiere of X-5s Zaniac
who we learns became a big film star. 1977
was a massive year for movies and this was
of course when Star Wars dropped. At that
point it was the biggest movie of all time
with Blockbusters becoming a major thing after
the release of Jaws. That happened two years
prior and we saw an influx of films that revolutionised
cinema.
To the left on the news stand we can see two
defunct papers with the messenger and enquirer
both going out of business. Loki instantly
suspects that Sylvie isn't here because he
believes that the locations too safe.
-
In Season 1 she was of course hiding out at
apocalypses because changing things really
wouldnt make a difference. This was shown
when Loki visited pompei just before the volcano
erupted and wiped everything out. Doing this
meant that nothing at these points really
mattered as it would all be erased before
it could make an impact.
However as we see Syvlie creating a life for
herself and doing this whilst off in a branched
timeline.
Now as Loki and Mobius walk towards the cinema
we can catch a Kingo Poster up on the wall.
As we learned in Eternals he's created a film
dynasty in which he becomes a big actor and
then pretends to be their son.
Now as we get to the premiere we see a poster
for the movie which actually has a lot going
on with it. X-5 is going under the name Brad
Wolfe who was the alter ego of Zaniac in the
comics.
That had Brad growing up in a neglectful household
but he channeled this negativity into become
an actor. Starring as Zaniac this was a monster
movie that saw him donning costumes like the
classic universal films. Things like The Wolfman
and Frankenstein have beomc legendary and
Brad was expecting the same stardom from this.
However when he was in costume about to film
a scene an explosion caused him to mutate
into Zaniac and become the character. Acting
out the movies script in real life he ended
up kidnapping women and carrying out mass
murders.
Zaniac was stopped by Thor and after being
subdued he was then arrested.
We discovered that in the explosion he'd been
possessed by a demonic entity that was controlling
him and killing people. Upon wolfes death
this burst forth from his body and the TVA
actually had to go back in time and stop it.
Now this isn't really inline with that and
instead X-5s just playing the part without
the other stuff involved. Mans popularity
is rising through the roof and we even see
in the crowd people holding up signs to marry
them.
Last week there was a lot of talk about how
the tva had taken away their lives and that
theres the temptation to go out and live one.
This is something that Mobius shuts down later
on with them asking about his jet-ski lifestyle.
As we learn X-5 was sent out undercover but
in the end he was tempted with having a real
life.
come on Mobius youre gonna ruin my life here
Making something for himself he's now seen
as a superstar.
He's rumoured to be hooking up with Bridgette
Bardot a former model from the time who also
starred in lots of movies. X-5 is probably
a bit of a narcissist so all the stuff he's
doing now makes a lot of sense.
Man even painted the letters X and 5 on his
gloves in the tva showing that he wanted to
stand out more than everyone else.
Mobius says.
Will there be a zaniac 2
In the comics we of course know they never
got to make one and due to what happens here
we know that wont be the case either.
We then get the line.
I used to work with this guy
Which may be riffing on this.
hes a friend from work
X-5 plays a long at first pretending he's
glad to see em but he rushes out which leads
into a big chase. Forgot to say but I love
Lokis seventies style tux and outside we see
B-15 grabbing his temp pad.
Leading to a big chase this ends with Loki
going through Strand Lane which is a centre
point for Theatre and music halls during the
19th century. Its still retained some of these
so it makes sense as to why the premieres
here.
X-5 manages to use a time twister to get himself
out of there which are items weve seen in
the series before.
Loki ends up creating an illusion that theres
a crowd of people and we get a hint to this
being magic due to the amount of people changing.
When X-5 first runs around the corner theres
a smaller crowd whereas when he moves into
it way more pop up.
Loki also duplicates himself which is a move
that he did during the first Avengers for
crowd control.
Growing his horns in the shadows these of
course belong to his helmet and it sort of
gives the impression that he's a kind of devil.
I have the theory that Loki will end up taking
over the position of He who remains which
is something I think the series has been spelling
out to us.
The opening shot had him running in front
of the statue and he also referred to the
character as the devil.
-
Loki clearly has this darker side to him too
which I think highlights that he should take
over. He knows that the war is coming and
though he thinks people should get free will
he did agree with what He Who remains
was doing.
-
With it comes a cost and he might be the only
one who knows that so in the end I think he'll
take over.
This is something that happened int he comics
too and during the young Loki book he discovered
that the older version of him was ruling over
it all. Now the comics and live action stuff
is never one for one but yeah...just something
to thing about when going over the series.
Now from here we cut to the title sequence
and shoutouts Ryan Arey last week for going
into what the title sequence signifies. He
pointed out that almost all of the letters
come from other films that Loki featured in
with there being the type face for thor, avengers,
dark world, ragnarok, endgame and so on.
The letters signify that we are dealing with
a number of different Lokis but its all black
and white in this word to show that they're
still Loki.
Now if youre enjoying the video and wanna
support the channel weve got some loki inspired
merch just below on the shelf at the bottom
of the video. These unique designs make you
stand out from your other variants and theyre
limited to just the shows run so make sure
you get em quick. We also have Ahsoka themed
ones and a little theory time so yeah, check
em out if you enjoy the videos.
Now back at the TVA they check out X-5s temppad
a little closer and see that its been modified.
Taking it to OB we catch him creating a way
to fix the loom which I think might lead into
some things happening next time. I know some
of you dont like when we discuss trailers
early in teh video though so I'll save that
for the end in case you wanna duck out.
Giving them the official handbook this is
something he also threw to Loki last week
and we learned that he wrote it himself. He
created all the TVA gadegets too and I actually
feel like OB may be a bigger power in the
show. As we saw last time he never got his
memory wiped and this is why he remembered
mobius but mobius didnt remember him.
Because he invented everything that means
he also invented the temp pad which is the
key to time travel. Someone who could do this
would be extremely important to Kang and we
may even find out he had a hand in the chair
from quantumania.
I feel like he may be integral to the operation
of the tva to the point that Kang couldnt
afford to wipe his memory. Wiping his memory
would remove all of his knowledge and therefore
it was kept.Thus he had to just be shuffled
out the way so he could still fix stuff but
was never involved in the main tings.
We can also catch an little mini alligator
on his desk which could be a nod to one of
the loki variants.
Up with KC we can catch a postwoman in the
background with this idea of them coming from
the truck last week.
We see theres a lot of theories about whats
going on including Ravonna. We also get it
confirmed that Ms Minutes is down but as we
now she likely abandoned the TVA. We discover
that though Renslayer deleted all evidence
on her temp pad that they can track the last
message.
During this we also see Loki and Mobisu' desk
whiuch makes a return from earlier in the
series. This was where Loki first properly
talked with Ms Minutes in episode 2. She was
able to dodge out the way and Loki wondered
whether she was a hologram or a recording
that knew the future. Clearly she knew the
way time was supposed to play out though which
was mirrored in he who remains who was able
to dodge out of the way of Sylvies attacks
due to him already knowing how the conversation
would go.
Now they learn Ms Minutes was the one who
was working with Ren slayer which we saw playing
out during season 2. When we first cut to
Ravonna during the 7 minute mark of the finale
we could catch that her temp pad was downloading
things on the organisation.
this isnt what I asked for
And I think Ravonna then travelled out to
the place that Victor Timely is located at
which we'll see later in the season. Taking
a shine to the temppad KC starts to study
it and we see as the interrogation starts
off with X-5. He knows their tactics though
so it proves more than difficult.
I loe the way the wall is orange and the floor
pannelings the same colouyr as the prison
uniform and it gives such an awesome colour
style to the scene. X-5 keeps correcting them
that he's called Brad showing that he's really
became attached to that life. He even taunts
B-15 over this and rips into Loki about how
hes now a reformed villain but all he does
is make things worse. Bringing up his mother
Loki inadvertedly caused her death in thor
the dark world though this version of him
hadnt experienced that yet. However he had
seen it play out on the holoprojector so was
aware of what happens with her.
youre a villain youre good at it
This kinda pushes Loki into bringing out his
darker side which we see him leaning into
more later on in the epsiode. There's definitely
this idea of both him and X-5 playing up their
dark sides and going after what they want.
Might be a reach yeah but early on at the
premiere we could see the tagline for the
Zaniac poster saying no one can escape his
terrible craving for blood.
This is something I feel thematically runs
throughout the episode with Zaniac even being
a character that sort of reflects Loki. Zaniac
was someone that wanted to be a hero but they
gave into their darkside due to the demon
inside of them. Loki has this darker side
too and though hes trying to be a hero he
has this other side pulling him back.
X-5 very much also is a reflection of Loki
as well and in a lot of ways he sort of reflects
the...let's say...less charming side of his
personality. X-5 is selfish and out for his
own ends which is something that Loki also
was too. He put his own feelings above the
TVA and wants the fame, acceptance and notoriety
that comes with it. This is something that
Loki was after too with him going against
his family and asgard to achieve his own thing.
Against the walls we also see pipes and hoses
leading into other areas of the tva but these
create linear looking structures hanging off
the sets. You might have noticed throughout
the episodes that there's lots of pipes and
lines going off into other which create this
idea of timelines built into it all.
Huge shoutouts to our guy MT who noticed this
last week after pointing out the funnel above
OBs head someone resembles the timelines and
the temporal loom. These pipes are all getting
collected into one place which then goes to
OB who fixes it. Looking at the show as a
whole these strands are all connecting together
on the timeloom which OB is pulling together
an also fixing.
Again I feel like he may be way more important
than we know and this series might even end
up being about him in the same way the first
one was more about Sylvie.
Now Mobius says.
Brad who
And he even promises to return him to the
timeline so he can continue being a star.
X-5 points out the fallacy in the entire TVA
and asks who he really is on the timeline.
Planting the idea in his head I do think that
we will eventually see what Mobius' is. I'll
talk about this in the trailer section part
of the video but he clearly touches on a nerve
which makes him punch him.
Mobius has lost it so much he even questions
who was following who and watch as they calm
down with some Key Lime pie.
There's not anyone here who serves it and
due to the name being Automat I think this
is just created and cloned. The pies themselves
could even signify the variants and how theyre
all kinda similar but not exactly alike.
Again going to the set design that we have
here, either thing is either orange or lime
green colour. Whether it's the crust, the
ceiling or the floor its all sort of divided
up into these two tones. This somewhat ties
into Loki himself with his colours also being
shades of this.
Also looking at the clock hanging from the
roof there's not actually anyway to tell what
the time is. Theres several hands all just
point out randomly with there not really being
any time in the TVA.
Loki opens up about his anger and talks about
how he invaded new york and then tried to
use the mind stone on Tony. He admits he lost
it and tried to kill Tony by throwing him
out the window which both happened during
Avengers.
Also to this version of Loki that happened
like a week ago with him escaping during endgame
and then going to the TVA.
Man then got to he who remains within a couple
of days and I think to him the avengers was
probably just last week.
Now they have a heart to heart about Mobius
and the life he was supposed to live, saying
that this is infact his life. We get it cleared
up that they now know they were kidnapped
variants who were drafted into this much in
the same was Loki was in Season 1. I think
what Loki as a whole will do is show us the
creation of the tva and it's fall which we've
already seen due to he who remains. I'm guessing
victor timely will show its beginnings and
then we'll spend most of our time here when
the organsiation started to crumble.
Cutting to the end of time I feel like the
castle is the last known headquarters with
that rock being all that exists of organisation.
MT last week did a big video breaking down
all the connections to black holes which appear
in the credits and lines of dialogue.
-
He theorised that we actually see the TVA
located in its own black hole which will exist
at the end of time until theres nothing left.
Now Mobius is clearly scared that if he discovers
he had a good life he'd want to go back to
it and somebody get that man a Jet-Ski.
Either way they realise that X-5 found Sylvie
but that he didn't alert her so he could keep
living her life. I dont think that Sylvie
would recognise him either as he wasnt someone
she ran into in season 1. I know most of her
life was spent running from the TVA but ey,
at least they kept it consistent.
Now we watch as OB goes to the temporal loom
which is where we see it firing up and getting
more unstable.
Now it's theory time theory time
So I think that eventually this is gonna overlord
and potentially explode causing bigger fractures
in the multiverse. I think that this is what
Sylvie was up to last week with her probably
travelling back her with Loki. When she was
climbing out the lift she said.
-
And therefore I think a future loki and sylvie
had teamed up to return to this moment when
the temporal loom hits critical mass. Looking
at the environment when this was happening
the walls and lights were going haywire which
probably links to this.
I think this season will be about trying to
fix the temporal loom which is why they have
to get help from Victor timely. All these
scenes show its.
Room status unstable
I think the series will focus around fixing
this to save the multiverse.
The temporal aura is also said to be invalid
so they have to to find a way to lock this
down.
Anyway that's the end of theory time theory
time.
Now Loki and Mobius decide to go back to X-5
which is when they decide to play things the
hard way. It basically turns into Loki locking
them intogether and him busting out a crushing
temporal doorway to get what he wants.
We actually had a little nod to this last
week as you could catch a poster warning not
to get stuck inside the doorway.
Loki also says that he's wrote a script of
his own.
-
Which goes just beyond brad being an actor.
As we saw with He Who Remains he had a stack
of paper showing everything that everyone
was gonna say but this only went up to a certain
point. In the end both Lokis went in different
directions and are now out creating a script
of their own.
Loki fully plays into his villainous side
which he may need if hes gonna lead the tva.
Thats kinda how I think things are gonna go
with Kangs empire literally crumbling around
us in the opening scene of episode 1.
I think this scene works really well with
him literally boxing X-5 in in order to get
the answers.
Watching the box get smaller and smaller as
the music ramps up just buils so well and
in the end it cranks up the tension so much.
Now as X-5 falls we can also see some scars
on his arms. Shoutouts to Erik at New Rockstars
for pointing out last week that this actually
lined up with his armour which we could see
when he was standing with his gloves around
his neck.
These scars lined up with a scratch across
his armour showing that they were all likely
created in the same blow.
Now from here we cut to B-15 and KC entering
the temporal loom room. I think it was cosmic
wonder who pointed out first that this looked
like the door to cerebro from X-men with it
possibly being a precursort to the MCU version.
Ke Huy Quan just kills it here.
- were all gonna die
And KC starts fanboying over OB writing the
tva handbook. Again it shows how important
he is to the organisation but how shoved out
the way that he is.
MT was saying he might actually be the villain
of this series with him orchestrating the
chaos that we see play out. Man was shoved
out the way for centuries and thing may even
be his revenge.
OB suggests that they either get Ms Minutes
to return or find he who remains probably
teasing whats gonna happen next week. Both
Kang and Ms Minutes were the ones that took
his work and used it as a way to take over
everything. Thus geting back to them might
be the endgame that eventually leads to him
being the big bad
From here we cut to a branched timeline in
1982 which is where we saw Sylvie at in the
post credits scene last week. This showed
that shes not been here a full year and they
do a great job of keeping things inline with
Mcdonalds in the 80s.
The sign says over 40 billion served whereas
these days its over 300 billion.
Her co-worked aslo said.
try our new chicken nuggets
Shoutouts to Erik Voss for pointing out these
were first introduced in select stores during
1981 which builds off the line. We also get
a couple of lines with sylvie and I kinda
feel like she's aware of everything.
can you fill these straws
This is kinda like how he who remains knew
what was coming before it did or you know...might
be a reach.
Either way stuff like this has made her a
star employee as she already has 5 of them
on her name badge.
This scene was actually released by McDonalds
earlier in the year as theyre doing a loki
tie-in alongside the show. X-5 is also super
nervous too.
-
Which we later learn is due to Dox's plans.
I'll explain how this works later on because
you might be wondering how certain points
in timelines can be wiped out yet still have
existed at some point.
On her lunch break Loki lays it out and talks
about how he saw her in the future at the
TVA. We see how shes starting to get more
inline with how she looked in the elevator
as shes now got her green coat and hairstyle
from that.
You can also catch her wearing her normal
boots though showing shes still got some of
the old Sylvie in there.
We can also see shes got an Ankh symbol for
an earring which means life. Sylvies found
a new one here and just wants to be left alone
and live her life here. Now Loki talks about
her theory time and he says that he feels
the same way too.
However Sylvie says.
- future not written.
This is something they discuss a lot in the
terminator franchise and it wrestles back
and forth between free will and fate. As we
know though Sylvie will end up there which
to me shows that someone else is still in
charge.
Personally I think that Loki will take over
which was foreshadowed during the opening
shot of the season.
X-5 desperately just wants to get back to
the sacred timeline as he's well aware whats
about to happen. Clearly jittery Mobius plays
to his ego about Zaniac which he passes off
as elevated horror. Mans making cinema I heard.
Some of that A24 ish...A1977 ammiright.
Nah but the seventies was a golden age for
this with the exorcist releasing in the decade.
Now X-5 going wild in the car park makes her
enchant him and see Dox's plan. I love how
Sylvie reveals her costume as well which her
changing her clothes from her mcdonalds uniform
stepping closer to the future version.
Entering a giant hall we see as theyre mass
pruning the branches and wiping out trillions
of lives. Dox is clearly still indoctrinated
to the idea of what the tva was set up for
with her describing it as a mission.
our mission is compromised
She also had war medals on with the timekeeper
heads showing shed dedicated her life to this
entier thing. It speaks to how some will still
continue on their life even when theyre shown
its wrong and highlights the blind faith the
tva had in their leaders. This idea of faith
was highlighted in the murals last week with
there being several images that went towards
the idea of religion. The time keepers had
their hands pressed together like a prayer
and those on the ground we praising them like
a god. We really start to get the idea of
the cost here though with the tva staring
at the timeline disappating destroying countless
lives.
Now you might be wondering how this works
when people will exist in moments before they
were pruned. I think it happens the same way
as incursions do in the comics which are basically
when two worlds crash into each other. There
are ways to avert this by destroying the other
world or finding a way to pass through the
earth. Still though hitting this earth wipes
out everything in it both forwards in time
and backwards as well. Thats how people like
Old Man Logan can exist in the future with
his past being a branch.
Now say they travelled to 2010 and pruned
it from there it would still continue to wipe
out things in the old man logan future.
How this works is that its like a ripple effect
in which the explosion starts off from the
impact point and then travels forwards and
backwars through time.
Now say someone pruned the branch we're in
now, technically you from yesterday would
be wiped out along with you from today. However
this would happen in a ripple effect with
you from last month getting wiped out first,
then last week and so on. Makes you realise
you might have little time left to hit the
thumbs up but thats how the timeline wiping
out works.
Now some timelines survive so we can still
have multiversal stories but large sections
off the multiverse are wiped out. Howard the
duck movie, gone, morbius...yeah fingers crossed
mate.
I feel like this ending kinda echoes the one
from epsiode 2 in season 1 in which Sylvie
did something similar. She ended up bombing
the tva to save the timelines whereas here
it's reversed to do the opposite effect.
Either way Renslayers temppad is fijnally
tracked and Sylvie returns to the branched
1982. Here we can catch her listening to Kozmic
blues by Janis Joplin which itself has a deeper
meaning. Performed at Woodstock in 1968 The
song starts off with the lyric time keeps
moving. This of course reflects whats going
on here but beyond that it's got another layer
to it. The song is about trying to stay optimisitc
even if reality constantly lets you down.
Sylvie has tried to carve out her own life
here and find happiness but inevitably she's
come up short.
Though she says she to Jack she thinks she'll
be in tomorrow that likely isnt the case as
we close out with her starting up He Who Remains
Device. This has appeared in the credits and
it was left on the table at the castle. This
is where the power derives from and we theorised
last season that it was linked in with the
device Tony Stark created as the Quantum realm
GPS. This was something that wrapped around
the front of the hand.
I'm guessing next week she may jump across
time and we could see potentially the Victor
Timely episode.
Also huge shoutouts to Scarlett Witch News
on twitter for spotting in the credits that
you can see a post note that says Hex Moment.
Theres also a diagram looking like the symbol
on the darkhold so good catch cos I completely
missed that.
Now as for my thoughts on this entry, I felt
it was a slight step down from last week with
it mainly being set up and reuniting the characters.
Stuff like that I always feel is kinda by
the numbers cos you know that they need to
meet back up and they sort of draw it out.
So where they need to really perform is in
the execution which I think was done brilliantly
throughout. Tom Hiddleston really got to come
into his own here and he balanced to torturing
scenes with the more personal ones brilliantly.
Going from the pie scene to the torture one
worked really well and helped keep the dynamics
of the show up. From there jumping to mcdonalds
and then into the big pruning scene, it just
kept it working and made the episode way better
than it couldve fallen into the trap of being.
I still dont think it quite hit the heights
of last week but I'd still say this was a
solid entry even if it wasn't perfect. I love
the handheld camera feel that the episodes
all have and again the direction and set design
is stellar. Guessing things are gonna ramp
up next week anyway and yeah let me know your
thoughts before we get into the trailer.
Now this bit coming up could contain spoilers
and though we're breaking down the public
trailer it may be stuff you just dont wanna
know. Do me a favour yeah, just hit the like
on your way out and hopefully I see you in
the next video.
Now for you guys whove stayed I have a feeling
that Mobius will end up back at his Jetski
place as we saw in the trailer how Loki arrived
at a location that sells them. I'm guessing
Mobius might return back to his life and go
there which is when Loki will go to try and
pull him out. It did seem like he was time
slipping again so maybe something happens
with the loom that causes this again.
I think next time they'll track down Victor
Timely which will also take them to where
Ravonna Renslayer is. This looks like it takes
place at the chicago fair and it was used
as the post credits scene for quantumania.
On screen we could catch Victor Timely showing
off the temporal loom and thus they'll need
him to fix the one in the present.
Victor Timely is a variant of Kang who travelled
back to the past after suffering several defeats.
In the past he used his knoweldge of the future
to create incredible inventions and he built
the town of timely up around him. Kangs whole
MO is that he wants to rule and no matter
what point he travels to time in thats all
he wants to do.
I think they might even grab this one from
the stage and take it back with them and then
swap everything out so that the timelines
saved. This was potentially what Loki saw
Sylvie going and its possible that Timely
goes to the TVA with them. There was a shot
in one of the promos where we could see a
model of the suit mobius wore in episode 1
with Jonathan Majors clearly being at the
end of it.
So I think theyre possibly bringing it all
back to the TVA where they'll try and replace
the loom.
I think it would be a good way to take things
if Victor Timely was a good guy and it would
show how you never know which version of kang
youre gonna get. Sometimes youll bump into
a villain sometimes theyll be good guys and
we might even see some turn from good to bad.
I do like the way that the show is going though
and you never know whats coming round the
corner. Sure there are these brief things
because of where time travel goes but we will
see as we get into it.
Please drop a like on the video and if you
want to support the channel as a member of
the Spoiler Society then please click the
join button.
You'll get early access to videos every week
and it goes such a long way to helping us.
If you wanna get some heavy spoilers merch
we've also got our t-shirt line located just
below the video that will let you pick up
all kinds of tops like our Theory time one,
house of the dragon stuff, marvel tees and
a lot more.
We drop new designs on there all the time
too so definitely keep an eye out for them.
Now if you want something else to watch we
have a video on screen right now _____________________
With that out the way, huge thank you for
sitting through the video, I've been your
host and I'll see you next time. Take care,
Peace.